kaltschnäuzig und empathielos das wird
Christina Schröder die ehemalige CDU
Bundesfamilienministerin den CSU-Chef
von bayerischen Ministerpräsidenten
Markus Söder vor der Grund ihrer Attacke
gegen den bayerischen
Ministerpräsidenten ist diese Impfung
Forderung an Jugendliche von dem
CSU-Chef
ich sehe ich konnte er gesagt er hat
nicht glauben als ich diese Bemerkung
gehört habe und habe es noch mal geprüft
ob er das wirklich so gesagt hat denn
ein Aldi was Jugendliche in den letzten
zwei Jahren hier in Deutschland ertragen
mussten was ihnen alles genommen wurde
an teilweise unwiederbringlichen
Ereignissen was wir aus den
jugendpsychiatrien hören mit welchen
sprunghaften Anstieg an psychischen
Störungen ist bei Jugendlichen geht und
eine Schulschließung rede ich gar nicht
und dann so zu tun als würden
Jugendliche quasi
der Impfungen der Party vorziehen da da
war ich über diese Kaltschnäuzigkeit und
über diese empathielosigkeit weiß
ziemlich fassungslos du sollst das bei
uns Gerona Politik rücksichtslos
gegenüber Kindern und Jugendlichen ist
ich finde schon dass gerade in Bayern
aber auch generell in Deutschland die
einen riesen Teil der Last der Pandemie
Bekämpfung Kindern und Jugendlichen
auferlegen und das ist ja kein
Naturgesetz dass man das so machen muss
die meisten europäischen Länder machen
es anders
z.b. haben viele Länder in der zweiten
und in der dritten wendel Welle die
Schule nicht mehr geschlossen manche
Länder wie Schweden haben sie sogar nie
geschlossen wir in Deutschland haben
europaweit mit den allerlängsten
Schulschließungen unter anderem auch
weil wir z.b. Erwachsenen Arbeitnehmern
in Büros und keine derartigen Lasten
auch verlegen wollten und haben wir es
eben auf den Rücken von Kindern und
Jugendlichen gemacht werden sich auch
kritisch über den Satz von Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz geäußert es gebe bei der
Corona Bekämpfung keine Route Linie was
ist daran problematisch
das war noch so ein Satz so ich dachte
ich ich bin irgendwie im falschen Film
selbstverständlich gibt es rote Linien
und zwar unsere Grundrechte in ihrem
Wesensgehalt in ihrem Wesensgehalt
dürfen Grundrechte nicht angetastet
werden gerade in einer Krise und dann zu
sagen es gäbe keine rote Linien und der
Bundestag der applaudiert auch noch
artig da muss ich wirklich dann Dank da
bin ich fassungslos und da finde ich das
auch kann ein Bundeskanzler wissen muss
was die Quintessenz unseres
Grundgesetzes ist nämlich dass der
Wesensgehalt von Grundrechten nicht
angetastet werden darf dem Ahnung von
Christina Schröder einer Politikerin
sprechen wir jetzt mit einem Fachmann
Professor Gerd schulte-Körne Direktor
der Jugendpsychiatrie am Klinikum der
Uni München ist uns zugeschaltet ich
küsse sie
wie sehen Sie die Situation wenn Sie die
jungen Patienten betrachtende die auch
zu Ihnen kommen
wir leben eine wahnsinnige Belastung bei
den Kindern und Jugendlichen vor allen
Dingen sind sie zunimmt depressiver
haben Ängste und vorhin auch Essstörung
haben total zugenommen und viele Kinder
und Jugendliche sind durch die Corona
Pandemie so belastet auch Familien wurde
vorher gedacht hätten die kommen gut
durch aber die Ressourcen sind einfach
aufgebraucht und wir bieten zu wenig
Hilfen an die Wartelisten sind sehr sehr
lang wie sieht das bei Ihnen im Haus aus
und was kann man tun wenn man schneller
einen Platz benötigt
akuter Not sonst würden sie nicht zu
ihnen kommen was passiert mit denen wenn
es passiert mit deinem stark abgemagerte
Mädchen beispielsweise bis 4 Monate
lange auf einen Therapieplatz warten
muss ja das ist eine berechtigte Frage
des wir versuchen eben dann Hilfen zu
geben für die Familien die sind ambulant
angeboten wenn es denn ganz schwierig
wird kommen sie akut in die Klinik und
wir versuchen eben das Gewicht zu
stabilisieren oder sie gehen dann in die
Kinderklinik zur Gewichtszunahme aber
insgesamt ist es eine sehr
unbefriedigend Situation warum verlieren
die Politiker auf den den Blick dafür
für die ja für die Post
Koronarerkrankungen für die
psychosomatischen Erkrankungen was ist
danach irgendwas ist was ist Ihrer
Meinung nach der Grund dafür muss was
muss passieren jetzt warm in der neuen
Regierung
und wir müssen einfach
ich muss die Politik viel mehr in den
Fokus nehmen und dann zusätzlich
brauchen wir eine viel bessere
Versorgung Darm immer noch zu wenig
stationäre Betten für Kinder die
psychisch krank sind und es ambulante
Versorgung System ist auch viel zu knapp
bemessen
Professor Schulte Cana vielen Dank für
die Innenansichten sehr gern